what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and i know a lot of you
out there love to stay up to date on
spiderman no way home well recently just
a few days ago it was revealed how kevin
feige the president of marvel studios
went over to sony and got spider-man in
the mcu we're talking from captain
america civil war to spider-man
homecoming to spider-man far from home
to now
in no way home and hopefully fingers
crossed the start of the true
spider-verse not only did kevin feige go
over to sony and get spider-man in the
mcu but ultimately made it to where
spider-man would severely shape the
mcu's future i mean the hype right now
for spider-man no way home is off the
charts and it's all due to kevin feige
toby maguire showing up in no way home
and andrew garfield showing up in no way
home hopefully are all thanks to this
story right here and before we dive into
the story be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on the mcu and so
you can enter our giveaway ending this
month giving away a spider-man figurine
this was provided by sidekick central
they're super awesome check them out on
instagram all you got to do to enter
subscribe to my channel and cosmic
culture will link that down below now
this story is coming to us from a book
that has just been released that is
getting a lot of attention right now
that book is called the story of marvel
studios the making of the marvel
cinematic universe and in this book it
tells the story about how marvel studios
got spider-man in the marvel cinematic
universe because remember at that point
in time marvel studios could not use
spider-man in the mzu because they had
zero rights plus not to mention sony was
making their own spider-man films at the
time with andrew garfield and they
planned on making a spider-man 3 with
andrew garfield still however we kind of
have kevin feige to either think or
blame depending on your views of the
amazing spider-man series that we did
not get that third film here's the story
according to this book on how it all
happened so sony had really really big
plans for the amazing spider-man
franchise with andrew garfield and as a
lot of people know they were going to
make a third one however this all
changed the day amy pascal a producer
for spider-man met with kevin feige sony
wanted to do a lot with spider-man
however the sequel the amazing
spider-man 2 had just flopped and they
didn't really know what to do and they
were kind of in a panic especially if
you consider the fact that they had a
lot of spin-off series in the spider-man
universe happening but at the same time
kevin feige and marvel studios are
sitting over there crushing it with the
mcu like destroying the box offices plus
fans really love their movies so after
the amazing spider-man 2 sony decided
that they want to do that they want to
be as big as the mcu so amy pascal a
producer and chairperson over at sony
motion pictures group called over kevin
feige and here's the story according to
the book on how everything went down it
says with a good sense of how they would
like to handle the character feige was
ready for his lunch with pascal what he
wasn't ready for was pascal's reaction
to his proposal the meeting was in her
office at sony as expected pascal wasted
no time in expressing her strong desire
to have feige be more directly involved
creatively in the making of sony
pictures is the amazing spider-man 3.
excited about the ideas her team
currently had pascal said she would send
feige the latest draft about halfway
through the delicious sandwich that she
had brought in i said amy in all
fairness it's not gonna work shares
kevin feige you see what amy pascal
didn't know is that kevin feige had
plans and ideas of his own to go forward
with spider-man just not in sony's
universe you see what amy pascal did not
know is that kevin feige actually had
plans of his own for spider-man just not
in the sony universe in the mcu so after
kevin feige tells amy pascal in all
fairness it's not gonna work this is
what he says we've sort of done that
before and i don't think i'm
particularly helpful there but kevin
feige was not done he had a counter
proposal the only way i know how to do
anything is to just do it entirely so
why don't you let us do it don't think
of it as two studios and don't think of
it as giving another studio back the
rights no change of hands of money just
engage us to produce it just pretend
it's like what dc did with christopher
nolan i'm not saying we're nolan but i
am saying there is a production company
that is doing this pretty well just
engage the services of that production
company to make the movie and the
production company he is obviously
referring to is marvel studios and it
says here that pascal was taken back she
was super surprised and then she got
upset it says at first i was super
resentful she admits i think i started
crying and threw him out of my office or
threw a sandwich at him i'm not sure
which then she started to think it
through by the 5th spider-man movie we
weren't giving them anything new and i
have to be honest about it we were
trying so hard to be different we even
went into places to be different that we
shouldn't have we weren't fresh anymore
pascal continues the lucky thing is
kevin and i come from the same place in
terms of how we love peter i've been
working with kevin on spider-man movies
since sam raimi's he would come to the
meetings get everybody coffee and he
never said a word for years which makes
you love somebody because then when they
do open their mouth you realize that
they've been thinking all the big
thoughts and are really smart but never
had to hear themselves talk pascal
called feige back the next day after
their lunch the concept of a
collaboration between sony and marvel
studios had not left her mind after
hearing his specific thoughts on what to
do with spider-man in the mcu she admits
the idea of putting him up against a
world where everybody had everything and
he had nothing was a whole new way of
telling his story i thought gosh dang
that guy's smart and yeah he was and he
is really really smart he's the
president of marvel studios and i think
everybody could probably agree that
spider-man in the mcu is way better than
anything that sony could have produced
on their own now from there marvel
studios would sort of softly bring
spider-man into the mcu introducing him
in captain america civil war briefly
briefly but super iconically and also it
kind of makes you wonder because a lot
of us are wondering right now if they're
going to show the other two spider-man
toby maguire and andrew garfield in the
trailer if you think back to the civil
war trailers they actually showed
spider-man they showed his debut in the
trailers before the movie so there is
definitely a possibility that they could
do that for toby and andrew and of
course we know how it went civil war
homecoming spider-man far from home and
now spider-man no a home that could have
more hype than avengers end game this
movie has the potential to be the
biggest movie of all time if andrew and
toby are truly in it this movie is going
to destroy the box office it's just
simply going to be insane and people are
going to go back to the theaters and
re-watch this over and over and over
again i think i watched in-game like 10
times in the movie theater i'll probably
watch this movie more if toby and andrew
are in it in which of course a lot of us
are pretty dang sure i've had insiders
tell me that it's 100 sure a guaranteed
thing but of course we have to see but
spider-man actually really helped shape
the mcu obviously being one of the most
popular characters of all time if not
the most popular character multiverse of
badness and the whole concept of the
multiverse really shines when we're
talking about spider-man because it
opens the spider verse even if the other
two spider-man didn't come back we still
have the old villains from the other
universes this alone is enough for a ton
of people to want to go see this movie
and they are but that's the story of how
kevin feige went over to sony and got
spider-man in the mcu what a freaking
legend thank you kevin feige and thank
you sony for doing what you thought was
best for the character be sure to let me
know all of your thoughts about this in
the comments down below and don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest spider-man and mcu videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and now tick-tock
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you